our main story tonight concerns the
philippines it's the country that gave
us among other things bruno mars olivia
rodrigo and jollibee the single greatest
fast food mascot of all time he's a six
foot five b in a tuxedo top that just
wants to serve you fried chicken and
spaghetti what do we have that compares
to that terrifyingly large child
hamburger joker hello mr police i gave
you all the clues please
the winner here is clear
we've discussed the philippines on this
show before mostly thanks to their
current leader and self-proclaimed
dictator rodrigo duterte who has if
nothing else away with words
why do you have to you know
[ __ ] with us god damn it yes again i
repeat it [ __ ] you
now i know that is a striking amount of
swearing but you also cannot understate
just how brazen it is for the president
of the philippines a nation over 80
catholic to call the pope a son of a
[ __ ] that is a big deal imagine if joe
biden publicly told dolly parton to go
[ __ ] herself forget backlash he'd be
dragged from the white house by his feet
and rightly so
and while duterte's language may have
been shocking his actions have been far
worse especially his war on drugs it's
estimated that on his watch government
officials or vigilantes have killed up
to 30 000 people in violence which even
triggered the international criminal
court to launch an investigation into
possible crimes against humanity and
duterte has viciously targeted his
critics this senator who launched an
investigation into his drug war has been
languishing in jail for the last five
years and nobel peace prize winner maria
ressa and her news website rappler have
been buried in legal actions facing at
least 11 cases and 10 arrest warrants
since duterte came into office and the
thing is that's just the beginning
the philippines consistently ranks among
the top 10 deadliest countries for
journalists
reports say as many as 19 of them have
been killed since duterte took office at
news of one he replied just because
you're a journalist you are not exempted
from assassination if you're a son of a
holy [ __ ] that speaks not only to his
brutality but also to the incredible
bravery of journalists there because the
possibility of assassination is the kind
of thing that can thin out a workforce
if michael's jobs listing said
applicants must have some familiarity
with candle making and scrapbooking also
please note employees are not exempted
from assassination if they're sons of
[ __ ] i don't think anyone would work
at michael's anymore
now thankfully duterte's term is about
to come to an end presidents in the
philippines can only serve one six-year
term and elections are actually
happening there tomorrow and this is a
big election in every sense the
philippines is a nation of 100 million
people and turnout is often around 80
although unfortunately there are some
disconcertingly familiar faces running
in this duterte's own daughter sarah is
running for vice president a position
which is elected separately in the
philippines and to get just a little
sense of her here she is when she was a
mayor
punching a local sheriff
that she was angry with and it is just
not great that you can look at that and
fairly say well at least she's not as
violent as her dad
but there's also someone running for
president and it was actually pretty
likely to win who has an even more
alarming last name
a front-runner in the current polls
ferdinand bongbong marcos jr his father
declared martial law ruling the
philippines with a terrible human rights
record until a popular uprising ousted
him in 1986. his mother imelda still
famous for her shoes
it's true the son of a guy who
terrorized the philippines for years is
now the front runner to take over and
look i'm not saying that anyone should
be judged solely on their family name
it's just a little weird in his
particular case it'd be like if the most
popular frozen yogurt chain in the u.s
was called bin laden's froyo delights i
will say a frozen yogurt shop cannot be
called that i just wouldn't expect it to
be a national hit that is after all why
they changed it to pinkberry now
as for imelda marcos's gigantic shoe
collection that wasn't just a fun
personality quirk it was a sign of the
staggering scale of the marcos's graft
they embezzled billions of dollars from
the philippines to the point that it was
once recognized by the guinness world
records as the greatest robbery of a
government and it is a bit weird for
them to be handing out records for such
a terrible thing it's like giving lee
harvey oswald an award for most jfk's
shot but
the enormity of the marcos family's
theft makes how bongbong has described
his childhood on the campaign trail this
year
a little hard to swallow
my parents would never
let us forget
that this is not this is not yours this
is from the people everything we have
all the advantages that we have gained
any successes that we have achieved and
any comfort or privilege that we enjoy
comes from the people now i will say
this
that is not technically inaccurate
the marcos is a sort of the british
museum of families in that most of what
they have is [ __ ] stolen so
if you are wondering how on earth it is
possible for the son of the philippines
most notorious leaders to now be on the
brink of running the country that is
what this story is about and before we
start let's acknowledge
there is a lot of history between the us
and the philippines and none of it
reflects particularly well on us to give
you just a quick rundown first the us
bought the philippines in 1898 then
utterly brutalized them in their fight
for independence in the philippine
american war which resulted in 200 000
casualties then subjected them to 50
years of repressive and racist colonial
rule and then even after granting them
their independence in 1946 continued to
use the cia to meddle in their affairs
all in all it was an attitude of
unchecked imperialism that was and i do
not say this lightly borderline british
but
but the story
of the mark that hurts didn't it and it
should have done
but the story of the marcos dynasty
really begins in 1965 when ferdinand
marcos was elected and while initially
presenting himself as a reformer by his
second term facing dissent he cracked
down hard inventing or exaggerating
internal threats to justify imposing
martial law and that was a period which
was to put it very very mildly a bad
time to be in the philippines under
martial law some 34 000 were tortured
and thousands more were killed and all
the while the marcoses were siphoning
off money on an astonishing scale with
imelda particularly adept at spending it
imelda known as the iron butterfly would
become a notorious jet-setting socialite
and fashion icon amassing hundreds of
millions in jewels fine art real estate
her travels so luxurious she once
reportedly spent two thousand dollars on
chewing gum during a layover in san
francisco
she even forced an airplane departing
rome to make a u-turn because she forgot
to buy cheese okay hold on hold on i do
have some questions there
first what do you mean forced an
airplane
did imelda storm the cockpit did the
pilot say a soft prayer to see his
children again all because imelda marcos
had a hankering for pecorino also if you
forget to buy cheese in italy you're
okay
filipino cuisine is perfectly delicious
without it anyone who has eaten a single
plate of adobo knows there was no need
to introduce aged couches into the
equation there
but as the marcos has plundered and
mismanaged the country the average
filipino suffered badly the economy was
in crisis and the incomes of wage
laborers declined substantially to the
point that by the end of ferdinand's
time in office many filipinos were
surviving on less than two dollars a day
and while again bongbong is not innately
responsible for the actions of his
father he very much benefited from that
spending spree the marcos is lavished
money on their children including this
birthday party for their daughter
[Applause]
extravagant parties on the presidential
yacht decadent by the standards of this
catholic nation ferdinand junior
nicknamed bongbong governor of the
family's home province is the man in the
flashing bow tie what did i just watch
there
i honestly don't know what's more
unsettling about that the adult baby
emerging from a cake screaming mommy
or the fact that while bongbong looks
very young there he was actually a
governor then and honestly i would not
trust a man wearing that bow tie to run
anything i wouldn't even trust him with
the job that he's dressed for there
bringing out the birthday cake at an
olive garden
now the marcos were ultimately forced to
flee the country after a mass uprising
in 1986 but ferdinand held on to the
billions that he stole the family were
granted asylum in hawaii and took a lot
with them on the plane showing up with
seven million dollars in cash and gems
and 24 bars of solid gold engraved to my
husband
on our 24th anniversary
which is not remotely romantic
that anniversary present is the
pilfering billionaire equivalent of
handing your spouse an envelope of cash
labelled we have been married for 24
years as of today
but obviously they did have to leave
some things behind and for many in the
philippines it was a real shock to see
the sheer extent to which they'd just
been robbed
filipinos who used to be kept blocks
from the marcos private universe got a
20-minute kaleidoscope of unimaginable
luxury
wow
including the former first lady's
10-foot wide bed that's why a lot of
people here in the philippines are
disturbing as far as rey is concerned
the marcoses belong in jail he can come
back here in the philippines to face
what they do
to the people of the philippines
yeah it's funny seeing the wealth of the
rulers who ripped you off does tend to
put things into perspective it's kind of
like how after french workers learned
the majesty of versailles in the 18th
century the revolution was right around
the corner hold on they have four
gold-plated pipe organs yeah these
[ __ ] are gonna have to go
now in the end a government commission
was set up to track down and recover the
stolen money and assets but 36 years
later thanks to court delays and the
marcos is fighting them the whole way
they've only retrieved about 5 billion
or around half of what was estimated to
have been stolen this is actually
something that bong bong was directly
asked about when he ran for vice
president six years ago and his response
back then was pretty infuriating
apology
i cannot give what i do not have i do
not have what you are
i do not have control i do not have any
knowledge of any of the thing once again
let me repeat i cannot give what i do
not have yeah not great but also i will
say credit to the sign language
interpreter there who managed to get
across not just what he was saying but
also really communicate his whole big
angry crybaby vibe i'm just saying it is
pretty impressive that bongbong is
somehow the biggest baby in this story
and it also contains this [ __ ] guy
and yet despite being booed for that
response bongbong is now on the edge of
being elected president and that is
because over the past decade something
kind of remarkable has happened in the
philippines and that is history has been
rewritten
since the return of the marcoses
there's been a trickle of new
information in youtube
in google that's a revision of the
interpretation of martial law hello
[Music]
[Music]
wow that is a stark rewriting of a
terrible period and i do realize that
the us isn't exactly perfect here either
we grapple with our greatest monsters by
putting up constant reminders of them on
mountains in town squares and on crisp
20 bills
and this willful distortion of history
has been massively abetted by the
internet as the philippines frequently
ranks as the most online nation in the
world that is actually something that
duterte very much benefited from as he
wrote a wave of false stories paid
trolling and facebook engagement all the
way to the presidency in fact facebook
itself even called him the undisputed
king of facebook conversations a title
surprisingly not held by your uncle who
has some really hot takes on the vaccine
he thinks that you should know about
and the internet is now similarly awash
in facebook posts and tick tock videos
that both glorify and romanticize the
marcos family popular posts on facebook
have explained away ferdinand's
ill-gotten wealth saying that his
fortune came from treasure left by a
japanese general after world war ii all
that it was earned for being a fantastic
lawyer there's also this one suggestion
that marcos at one point gave breads to
a young michael jordan it seems to have
originated as a joke but has since been
passed around completely seriously and
let's just break this story down on
december 24th 1969 the marcos family was
in wilmington north carolina to
celebrate the holidays that actually
tracks because if you're a billionaire
from the other side of the world and you
want to celebrate the holidays in
america there was only one place that
you're going
and that's wilmington north carolina
then president marcos was walking in a
park and he saw a skinny child begging
for food he gave him a whole box of
nutribun and said bring this with you
child someday you will grow up to be
someone important so to be clear in this
story president marcos was walking
through a park holding bread
specifically nutribun a bread mainly
sold in the philippines meaning marcos
flew to the united states
with nutribun because he was like what
if we get to wilmington north carolina
my favorite holiday destination and they
don't have any bread there then he went
to the park and passed like 10 other
kids thinking none of you are going to
grow up to be important so you're not
getting any of my park bread then he saw
michael jordan and was like wait
i'm pretty sure that you are gonna be
important
so here have this bread that i brought
with me from the other side of the world
and then that kid grew up to be michael
jordan the greatest basketball player
who ever lived that is the single
dumbest story involving a young michael
jordan i've ever heard and i have seen
space jam
so that is just a taste of the online
nonsense which is successfully reframing
the marcos family history and at the
same time bongbong's main rival lenny
robredo the current vice president and
the woman that you saw challenging him
in that debate clip earlier has faced
vicious attacks online ranging from
false allegations that she has ties to
armed communist rebels to phony rumors
that she murdered her husband in fact
fact checkers have reported that almost
all the disinformation about robredo is
negative while any disinformation about
bongbong overwhelmingly puts him in a
positive light but maybe the most
fantastical lie that bongbong's campaign
has told is actually the most mundane
one that he is not the scion of a
political crime family he's just a
regular ordinary citizen who just
happens to be running for president in
fact here is how his wife described the
exact moment that he decided to run
you know six months ago he wasn't yet
sure what to do with no party no
and then one day we're watching
ant-man in the room and then he looks we
love marvel movies and then he looked at
me and he goes okay we're gonna do this
he told me i said do what run for the
presidency
no [ __ ] way
that did not happen
i am calling total [ __ ] on the idea
that bongbong decided to run for
president out of nowhere mid-marvel film
mainly because i can think of a much
more salient reason that he'd want to
run as president bon bon would hold sway
over the commission devoted to
investigating and recovering his
family's wealth as well as the tax
office which would be particularly
useful for him as the marcos have
refused to pay a tax bill that
reportedly amounts to 3.9 billion
dollars including penalties so bongbong
could easily tell his own administration
to just forget about his massive debt
which is clearly a very appealing idea
for him in fact when you think of it
ant-man could actually be the perfect
movie to inspire him to run for
president given that it's about a thief
whose questionable past is forgotten
after he rises to power using resources
that he also stole of course he [ __ ]
likes ant-man
but i will say bong bong's brand
relaunch has not worked on absolutely
everyone plenty of filipinos are still
opposed to him and to having the marcos
era rewritten in front of their very
eyes despite trailing bong bong
massively in the polls lenny robredo has
inspired huge rallies there and walt
walden bellow who is running against
sarah duterte for vice president has
been outspoken about just how outrageous
he finds all of this
marcos has
created a big public relations machinery
a social media to convince people try to
convince people that that the
14 years of martial lawn that the
collective nightmarian uh he's trying to
use social media and you know
his hundreds of trolls to say my god
golden years rouyan this is a family
that has raped the country it has not
apologized to the country okay and he
now wants to rape the country again [ __ ]
you marcos
yeah
well put
very well
and the thing is the thing is there it's
clear no matter how hard you try to
reinvent yourself there is always going
to be at least some people who remember
who you really are whether you're a new
college freshman trying on a british
accent or a massive tech oligarchy
trying to paper over its complicity and
violence and genocide hey mark i think
meta's really started to catch on just
give it a few more weeks maybe you're
doing great buddy
people are really pumped for this
look it has been truly amazing to see
the philippines election unfold because
in this election they're not just voting
on their future they're voting on their
past specifically which one do they want
to believe the one where ferdinand
marcos wreaked havoc on a country and
its people under martial law or the one
where he was somehow the greatest nba
scout of all time
and i know that most people watching
this are not eligible to vote in it
although if you are and you are watching
maraming salamatpo and to you let me
just say this i do get well you'll be
skeptical about a breakdown of your
politics from someone with what i can
only describe as big colonizer energy
and
who lives in a country that is frankly
no stranger to dishonest billionaires
who propel themselves to power with
facebook lies so look don't listen to me
but maybe do listen to your fellow
citizens who both remember the past and
are determined not to repeat it because
bongbong marcos has shown virtually no
remorse for what his father put the
country through and if the philippines
is to avoid more of the same graft and
violence that they've experienced over
the past 50 years they're going to need
these people and others like them to
continue bravely speaking out and
telling the likes of bon bon marcos if i
may use the poetic words of the
philippines current [ __ ] president
[ __ ] you
you